er ist ein in deutschland wir sind sie
richtig herzlich willkommen die die
zuschauer in diesen krisenzeiten starten
wir täglich mit einem corona kompakt so
auch an diesem freitag mit platz für
ihre fragen die heute professor dr
gérard krause beantwortet vom helmholtz
zentrum für infektionsforschung zunächst
aber der blick auf das was heute rund um
das corona virus passiert ist in bayern
gelten ab mitternacht schärfere ausgangs
beschränkungen nur wer wirklich einen
triftigen grund hat darf sein zuhause
verlassen
friseure wird nicht mehr geöffnet
baumärkte und gartenmärkte werden
geschlossen weil es sich in vielfältiger
form zu einer art freizeit idee
entwickelt hat dorthin zu gehen
wir werden auch die gastronomie ab
morgen grundlegend schließen
auch in hamburg und rheinland pfalz
werden gastronomische einrichtungen
komplett geschlossen
versammlungen von mehr als fünf personen
werden verboten
das werden wir jetzt unterbinden
schlicht und ergreifend weil es nicht
geht dass man nach wie vor am rhein oder
mosel sitzt oder den weinbergen oder was
auch immer und gemeinsame unternehmungen
vornimmt verantwortung für andere wollen
nicht alle tragen die versorgung in
deutschland mit lebensmitteln ist sicher
und trotzdem gehen die hamsterkäufe
weiter ich würde es schön finden wenn
viele leute nicht so viel einkaufen
dürfen
es ist nämlich der fall dass ich weil
ich keine hamsterkäufen mache kein
toilettenpapier in manchen denen mehr
bekommen und dafür wirklich hin und her
fahren muss luxusartikel toilettenpapier
das bringt kleinbetriebe die um ihre
existenz kämpfen müssen auf kreative
ideen in einer fleischerei in sachsen
gibt es zu jedem einkauf eine
klopapierrolle dazu nach dem motto nach
dem geschäft ist vor dem geschäft man
sitzt ja nur noch dann grübelt was man
machen kann
weil wir wirklich über jeden kunden
frohsinn und er spreche ich
für unsere ganze branche für alle
kleinen handwerksbetriebe alle kleinen
bäcker fleischer und deswegen sind wir
auf die idee kommen wir machen das jetzt
einfach mal und genau es geht schlicht
ums überleben
die johns hopkins universität gibt heute
die zahl der krone infektionsfälle in
deutschland mit 16290 an
seit gestern gibt es 2311
neuerkrankungen und hier ist jetzt
professor gérard krause aus braunschweig
zu bescheid vom dortigen helmholtz
zentrum für infektionsforschung und die
zahl die wir gerade gehört haben
die stimmt schon nicht mehr so ganz denn
stand 17 uhr meldet die hopkins
university über 18.000 infizierte in
deutschland
herr professor jetzt schon über 18.000
bestätigte corona fälle ist dass der
erwartete anstieg
und was sagt uns diese zahl ja das ist
der erwartete anstieg wir befinden uns
noch am anfang der epidemie die starken
zahlen werden weiter steigen
das ist der verlauf den wir jetzt
erwarten ist insofern nicht
verwunderlich wie weit geht dass nur
hoch was erwarten sie persönlich
ich bin kein vorhersage ich kann das
nicht sagen wie weit es gehen wird
aber wir sind auch auf dem aufsteigenden
schenkeln und üblicherweise kann man
eigentlich erst wenn man oben angekommen
ist sagen dass man oben angekommen ist
und das ist ja dieses große unbekannten
gefährlich von dem sie und ihre kollegen
schon seit längerem gewarnt haben vielen
dank herr krause für den moment auch
dafür dass sie noch ein bisschen bei uns
bleiben denn sie beantworten ja auch
später hier noch unsere zuschauer fragen
also bis gleich dennoch appelliert die
regierung vor allem an die vernunft und
die rücksicht der menschen um die
verbreitung des virus einzudämmen
doch wir haben es eben schon gehört sie
gucken sehr genau hin die
verantwortlichen von bund und ländern
denn wenn sich zu viele bürger weiterhin
in gruppen treffen oder sich
gastronomiebetriebe nicht an die
begrenzten öffnungszeiten halten
dann drohen tatsächlich weitere auslands
beschränkungen wegen der ausbreitung des
corona virus hat die polizei ihre
präsenz in der innenstadt von hannover
deutlich erhöht sie kontrolliert die
durchsetzung der öffnungszeiten von
geschäften
erklärt die bürger auf besonderes
augenmerk legen die ordnungshüter auf
die verhinderung von
menschenansammlungen jeder art die
devise abstand halten
[Gelächter]
die polizei setzt damit durch was
niedersachsens innenminister angekündigt
hat hartes durchgreifen gegen die
unverbesserlichen das ist keine übung
und das ist erst recht kein spiel und
das ist erst recht keine gängelei von
bürgerinnen und bürgern durch politiker
und wissenschaftler die sich wichtig
machen wollen das ist bitterer ernst
und deswegen wird die polizei auch mit
aller konsequenz einschreiten genauso
wie die kommunalen ordnungsbehörde für
deren arbeit ich mich an dieser stelle
auch schon einmal herzlich bedanke
verständnis bei den passanten
und vielleicht menschen dass herrn
merken ja okay es ist nicht gut was wir
machen
und wir sollten vielleicht wirklich nach
hause gehen weil die lage wirklich ernst
ich finde das gut weil ich gehört habe
dass es also corona feten gegeben habe
die sind im moment wirklich notwendig
halten sich bis zum wochenende nicht
deutlich mehr menschen an die vorgaben
könnte die bewegungsfreiheit weiter
eingeschränkt werden
dann droht eine ausgangssperre ja und im
laufe des nachmittages haben erst der
bundesländer schon weitere
beschränkungen beschlossen
aber es gibt auch andere sachen
lichtblicke auch wenn sie selten sind in
dieser corona krise aber so wichtig die
italiener haben es vorgemacht
leidenschaftliche balkon konzerte gegen
die angst und gegen die korona isolation
akasa im internet gibt es bereits viele
videos davon
das können wir auch hat sich jetzt ein
vater mit seinem sohn in kassel gesagt
und für die nachbarn musiziert ein
balkon konzert gegen den corona blues
der argentinische musiker diego und sein
neunjähriger sohn friderico wollen ihrer
nachbarschaft in kassel mut machen in
diesen zeiten in italien machen die das
auch hatten sie das auch gemacht gegen
diese krone situation in den strom und
in ganz italien
und dann dachte warum nicht hier wieder
die die aktion wir wollen einige
nachbarn machten spontan mit aber statt
nur vom fenster zu lauschen und
mitzumachen versammelten sich zahlreiche
schaulustige vor dem haus in kassel
das ist zwar nicht ganz nach der regel
zu hause bleiben aber für vieles die
musik eine willkommene abwechslung und
das ist einfach eine tolle sache in der
heutigen zeit wo jetzt irgendwie alle
langsam dann ein
zimmer koller kriegen und einfach was
für uns alle mit der musik zu machen
eine gute aktion also die leute waren
begeistert eigentlich und hat alles
gestimmt
die polizei rückte zwar an löste die
veranstaltung aber nicht auf viele
hielten abstand zu einander ähnliche
balkon konzerte hatte der gebürtige
argentinier bereits organisiert der 54
jährige wollte damit seinen sohn größten
der seinen geburtstag wegen corona nicht
mit freunden feiern konnte
ich habe mich ist das sozusagen ein
geschenk ist das mein papa das gemacht
habt schluss war ja noch sehr glück und
viel segen für mich gespielt musikalisch
liegt das balkon konzert in kassel zwar
hinter seinem italienischen vorbild
zurück aber für diego zählt der gedanke
fand es super
sehr schön super der stimmung und hätte
ich nie gedacht dass so viele leute
mitmachen könnten
er ist sich sicher musik macht bessere
laune
gerade weil viele wege cola nicht raus
können ja und alle die noch raus können
oder raus müssen die dürfen sich freuen
denn zum ersten mal seit jahren kostet
ein liter diesel unter einem euro lange
her dass der sprit so günstig war
doch der preissturz an den zapfsäulen
hat einen ernsten hintergrund und zwar
die weltweite angst vor einer rezession
der zufriedenen blick zur preis solle
tanken ist derzeit günstig 99 cent für
den liter diesel
erstmals seit jahren wieder unter einem
euro ich bin jetzt materie glücklich
also ich setze mir auch für die an
ganzen autofahrer ist das sehr
vorteilhaft jetzt günstig zu danken ist
schon ordentlich runter gegangen würde
ich sagen und da kommt man doch gerne
abends um halb zehn noch mal zur
tankstelle und geht noch mal eben
schnell tanken
ich glaube das haben wir seit 2002 also
der umstellung auf den euro nicht mehr
gehabt corona druckt die spritpreise
wenn die wirtschaft in die krise
gedrückt wird keine flugzeuge fliegen
keine waren transportiert werden sind
die sprit nachfrage und dann der preis
je länger die krise jetzt andauert desto
niedriger sind dann auch die preise das
geht so eins zu eins und zurzeit ist es
so dass wir gerade auf dem regionalmarkt
hier relativ günstige preise haben auch
super benzin wird immer billiger vor
kurzem noch kostete der liter 20 cent
mehr
gut für den geldbeutel mit einem kleinen
beigeschmack stichwort quarantine sehr
günstig aber wenn die leute alle zu
hause bleiben müssen dann können sie
auch kein auto fahren von daher aber nun
bitte nicht hamstern sagt der hd hat sie
was man nicht machen soll was es auch
schon gab in den letzten wochen dass man
sich den keller voll stellt mit sprit
weil das geht gar nicht das ist
lebensgefährlich könnte sein dass die
preise weiter sind mal was positives in
krisenzeit
das stimmt denn schon beim nächsten
thema werden wir wieder recht schnell
daran erinnert wie ernst die lage ist so
hat sich nämlich heute morgen der chef
des robert koch-instituts lothar wieler
sehr klar und sehr eindeutig an die
krankenhäuser und kliniken gewand zitat
ich erwarte jetzt dass die krankenhäuser
vorbereitet sind jetzt muss es so weit
sein
was bedeutet das für eine klinik wie
bereitet sie sich auf den crooner
betrieb eigentlich vor die
internistische intensivstation des st
josef hospitals in bochum 18 betten
haben sie und die sind meist voll belegt
zu über 90 prozent
und jetzt das corona gespenst vor den
türen mit patienten die wahrscheinlich
auch intensiv pflege brauchen werden
derzeit haben wir versucht freie betten
zu schaffen auch mit der hilfe von
anderen disziplinen insbesondere der
operativen intensivstation das ist uns
auch zum teil gelungen
also gehe ich jetzt gerade für eine
auslastung von etwa 80 prozent aus das
ist aber nicht der regelfall sondern
eben nur gelungen weil wir patienten auf
andere stationen verteilen könnten 80
prozent das heißt 20 prozent frei für
corona patienten das sind drei bis vier
betten
noch haben sie hier keinen corona fall
auf der intensivstation
zwei menschen liegen isoliert mit einer
bestätigten infektionen dazu neuen
verdachtsfälle und im labor gestern ein
weiterer fallen die vorbereitungen auf
corona laufen hier seit wochen dieser
raum etwa wird speziell für einen
schweren corona fall freigehalten
jedes krankenhaus hat eigentlich für die
normale versorgung ausreichend
kapazitäten aber für das was jetzt kommt
reicht es eben nicht räumlich bekommen
wir das in den krankenhäusern zum teil
hin apparate mäßig und personalmäßig das
wird unsere große herausforderung werden
vielen das pflegepersonal seit jahren
ein thema im krankenhauswesen jetzt
schlägt s voll durch besonders weil sie
fachkräfte für die intensivpflege
brauchen
es ist schon auch so dass wir sehr
kreativ gucken wo gibt's dann noch
intensiv personal was sich vielleicht
vor zwei drei vier jahren in den
normalen pflegedienst verabschiedet hat
und wir sind gerade dabei alle die in
unseren häusern arbeiten also wir haben
über 5000 mitarbeitende wir gucken schon
wer ist dort in den letzten jahren mal
auf der normalstation werden und wir
können die reaktivieren und sie setzen
auf die bereitschaft ihres teams die
menschen bringen sehr viel motivation
mit sehr viel einsatzbereitschaft mit
wir haben viele studentische aushilfen
die sich wieder melden bei uns arbeiten
möchten examinierte pflegekräfte die
wieder zu uns kommen möchten und
arbeiten möchten das versuchen wir jetzt
zu kanalisieren damit wir die menschen
auch dann haben wenn wir sie brauchen
das hospital ist auch eine uniklinik und
forscht deshalb auch unter den
studierenden nach geeigneten leuten dazu
das material problem seit anfang februar
sind zwei mitarbeiter nur damit
beschäftigt zu bestellen
mundschutz desinfektionsmittel alles
mangelware
für den beginn einer möglichen
patientenwille reicht der bestand sagen
sie aber für mehr nicht angespanntes
warten auf einen unbekannten feind wenn
wir die entwicklung aus italien
anschauen fürchte ich dass wir wirklich
weitere vorkehrungen treffen müssen um
dem herr zu werden
trotzdem hoffen wir natürlich auch alle
dass es in deutschland keinen so
schwerwiegenden verlauf nehmen wird
aber das ist eine hoffnung und keine
sicherheit sie haben sich vorbereitet so
gut es geht samt eines zelts draußen für
die krankenhausmitarbeiter für corona
test alle negativ bisher auf dass das so
bleibt das so wichtige personal weiter
gesund bleibt genauso wie die forscher
und virologen denen ja auch jetzt eine
große verantwortung zukunft im kampf
gegen das virus professor dr
gerard krause ist einer von ihnen vom
helmholtz zentrum für
infektionsforschung er professor sie
waren eben schon mal bei uns und wir
haben gemeinsam darauf geschaut die
krankenhäuser bereiten sich jetzt vor
auf viele schwerkranke patienten wird
das jetzt die nächsten tage wirklich
losgehen durch diese vorbereitung kann
man das ableiten
wir können ableiten dass wir mehr
patienten haben werden und deswegen ist
es sehr gut dass die krankenhäuser sich
frühzeitig darauf vorbereitet haben
das wird sicher helfen die schulen sind
dicht viele läden und restaurants auch
jetzt gibt es die ersten ausgangs
beschränkungen und auch weitere machen
wir damit genug aus ihrer sicht oder
müsste nach ihrer meinung noch mehr
passieren
ich bin der meinung dass diese maßnahmen
jetzt durchgeführt werden müssen das ist
schon richtig aber wir müssen unsere
aufmerksamkeit auf einen anderen bereich
fokussieren nämlich den bereich der
patienten die wenn sie erkranken
wahrscheinlich eine schwere erkrankung
haben werden
das sind menschen über 65 über 60 dass
menschen mit vorerkrankungen die eine
immunsupprimierten wirkung haben oder
entsprechende medikamente nehmen diese
menschen müssen betreut werden diese
menschen müssen ihre gesundheit
überwachen diese menschen dürfen nicht
unnötig in kontakt mit potenziell
infektiösen menschen kommen dh die
müssen ihre einkäufe nicht selber machen
müssen sondern man muss ihnen das essen
nach hause bringen es gibt ja dieses
beispiel was wohin gezeigt würde wurde
wenn diese menschen erste symptome
bekommt die müssen sofort auch in
ansprechpartner haben dass dem
nachgegangen wird dass die sofort
diagnostiziert werden dass die sofort
die entsprechende therapie haben können
ich bin überzeugt wenn wir unsere kräfte
darauf bündeln können wir vermeiden dass
menschen
auf intensivstationen landen müssen ja
gut das ich das nochmal so eindringlich
sagen wenn man das hört dann weiß man
eben was zu tun ist sei es als nachbar
als privatperson oder als jemand der
jemand betreut er gefährdet ist unsere
zuschauer fragen lernen mich nicht zum
beispiel der fragt wie lange ist man
noch anstecken nachdem man sich
infiziert hat und wieder genesen ist
wir gehen davon aus dass wenn man
genießen ist dass man nicht mehr
ansteckend ist und dass man deswegen
nicht nur nicht mehr anstecken ist
sondern auch wie man ist und deswegen
kein zweites mal an dieser selben
erkrankung erkranken kann gut zuhören
heike hat auch eine frage gestellt sie
ist friseurinnen und sie wundert sich
als solche dass die songs noch geöffnet
haben das heißt er mal 15 meter abstand
halten
ist in dem beruf leider nicht machbar
schreibt sie ja die frage ist berechtigt
tatsächlich kann man im schnitt
vielleicht noch ein paar monate oder
wochen verschieben das würde ich auch
denken dass man in diesem moment darauf
vielleicht verzichten muss wir hoffen
auf ein paar wochen schira david letzte
frage in vielen geschäften sind die
waren auf dem tresen ausgelegt schon
meine guten tag könnten ja mikroskopisch
kleine tröpfchen des personals auf wurst
oder kuchen landen ansteckend wenn ich
das dann esse nein diese krankheit
dieses virus wird nicht über
lebensmittel übertragen die normalen
verfahren und standards in denen wir
lebensmittel präsentieren zum verkauf
anbieten wie wir sonst auch gewohnt sind
sind genau die die auch davor schützen
dass entsprechende infektionen
übertragen werden dieses virus ist nicht
geeignet über den bund oder über die den
verdauungstrakt aufgenommen zu werden
danke für diese entwarnung im namen
unserer zuschauer zumindest für diesen
bereich und vielen vielen dank für ihre
zeit und die antworten professor krause
übrigens unsere corona kompakt das gibt
es auch auf youtube finden sie auch alle
bisherigen ausgaben und zwar auf dem
kanal der zdf heute außerdem können sie
uns weiter ihre fragen schicken
an unsere experten von denen einige wie
gerade hier im studio beantworten
die e mail adresse sehen sie auch
eingeblendet corona kompakt zdf.de